welcome back to the GameSpot stage here
at e3 2016 and this is brought to you by
airheads
I'm your host Mary and I am delighted to
be joined I'm a good friend Peter Brown
also gamespot review editor my oh my
so it's official and Phillipe from the
red barrels who delights in scaring
children everywhere you monster
we like to do and you do it quite well I
was given the ability to play your demo
for outlast 2 at PAX East scared the
[ __ ] out of me it's just absolutely
terrifying demo and I'm sure will show
some gameplay of it pretty soon but it's
like you guys create the most haunting
atmosphere and I think you guys have
learned a lot from the original outlast
that you're attributing to it we can
already see that you guys are bringing
back the camera with the battery you are
I never use it's always in the back your
mind but there's enough batteries
scattered around through the world but
it seems like you guys are carrying a
lot of elements from that original game
but what new elements are you guys
making for outlast 2 well we worked a
lot on the environments in the settings
so it feels like completely new we like
to have what I call the on do with the
water what the health feeling what the
hell's going on and we want to make sure
that that feeling is renewed every now
and then so that it never feels like it
becomes familiar with the first outlast
when you get to get to the DLC the
asylum almost felt like a familiar place
and we want to make sure we avoid that
with outlast 2 and now when you're
saying you put a lot of effort into the
environments which you guys absolutely
did in the first one we went to all
sorts of terrible places and you know
kind of culminates in just horrible
environments like you know sometimes you
don't even know where you are and this
is true in the demo as well where there
was some times where I was like am I in
a school and I'm in a hallway there's
lockers I'm not exactly sure where I am
but I'm in I know I'm somewhere I don't
want to be it looks like now you're
taking us to like the desert and middle
of nowhere but there are people there
there's an underground
what other environments do you have in
store for us well the game starts in
this village that the people have been
living there for 50 60 years maybe we we
were influenced by the Jonestown
incident in the 70s Jim Jones and during
the kool-aid the thing and know there's
going to be a river section there's
going to be a place where people have
syphilis which when it's really extreme
can look like leopard nipples is going
to be on the ground stuff please go on
yeah it sounds like you have like all
sorts of like really horrible and in
like speed of Jonestown I mean the
people of this town are clearly on the
kool-aid like they are drinking the
cocaine they're nuts and they're trying
to kill you they got pitchforks I mean
what's up with the people of the town's
people who are super unfriendly they
they are convinced that the end of times
are coming and actually it's going to
take place as at Sunday sunup so you've
got the one one night to look for for
your rifle trying to find her and they
are convinced that she she has something
special that you you're gonna figure out
what's happening with her by the end of
the game and it's really we're trying to
mess with the player's mind so that you
your sense of what's real and what's not
becomes confused and whenever you try
you think you understand what's going on
we're gonna put a new twist at you to
just things up yeah I mean in the demo
already as soon as I felt like I was
comfortable in one environment I was
immediately transported into another it
seems like you guys are allowing some
creative flexibility or allowing
licenses to all of a sudden just be in a
new environment without too much
explanation of why do you know the
original Ellis was quite successful it
was both too critical and fan acclaim
which is fantastic do you guys think
that that gave you more creative freedom
more Liberty to to be a bit more
experimental with this one
well definitely we allowed us to take
more time in the first game we have to
finish it before running out of money
this time we could try try some things
make some experiments and we we just
want to mess with the player's mind and
make something that we didn't want it to
feel like just a longer DLC so we
experimented we did some plate that's
about a year ago find out what worked
what didn't and now looking at the
results of the demo it seems that we
found the right amount of elements that
we can mix together without going too
far away from the brain out less and as
you mentioned that you basically had the
constraint of time and time is money
maybe because you have a little bit more
you are able to really make sure you
fine-tune to everything before you
I don't know but really polish it up
basically before you bring up says yeah
we're nor fully independent studio and
we sold about four million units of the
first out last so yeah I mean we're the
way I see it is that the first one was
like a solid double and this one we want
to knock it knock it out of the park
fantastic yeah going back to the
original you guys recently released a
comic that kind of bridged some of the
gap between the first and the second
outlast kind of hinting that I mean are
there going to be any characters that we
might see from the first one is there
any like kind of blending that we should
expect for fans of the original you're
going to see them in the comic books but
the the game itself it's mostly new
characters and that I mean even the guy
in the demo I don't think does too well
I don't even think I'm gonna see him in
the game this is such a great part and I
think this is where we start going into
the underground caverns so we've kind of
seen like the outdoor environment see
the village but now now we're getting
into like this underground area and when
you look down this part is absolutely
when you understand that these people
they're not there for camping yeah and
the player has some really good audio
feedback during these cues
if you guys watch the games the gameplay
that we have on GameSpot you'll hear the
player starts breathing really heavily
when he sees things that upset him which
is often but it's a really nice reminder
that something is so alarming that even
the character can't contain it
yeah and then this time we added the
more dialogue for the main character the
first one he wasn't talking this one he
will be buts mostly for us a narrative
too to just give more information to the
player one thing I'm really curious
about is how maybe you're considering VR
support if you are is that thing we hae
yeah a lot of people ask us about VR I
mean it's definitely something we have
the Deaf gets at the office yeah so we
always thinking about it but we're a
small team were 18 people so we got to
focus on one thing at a time we'll get
this one out of the door and then we'll
see what we decide to do after that but
yeah I mean obviously would be really
interesting to exploit VR with the in
the wall of our class of course the
mobility is sort of an issue when you're
what you know using a first-person game
yeah the joystick that does create some
disconnect absolutely yeah there are
there are some things that we're doing
that are not very VR friendly of course
so what would be best is just to get
build something from the ground up for
VR and not just bored to adapt whatever
we already have how what do you think it
horror is so popular in general because
it's one of those things that it turns
off a lot of people it also gets a lot
of people very excited like why is it
that you think that people love to be
frightened into I think it's some people
just being scared makes you feel alive
yeah it's those like natural instincts
like we're never running from predators
anymore it old
Jackrabbit Peter always trying to save
himself I mean like I never really do
get genuinely scared in my day to day my
biggest fear would be like I don't know
money and just making it day-to-day but
yeah the idea of like you know why I
love horror so much going to a scary
movie or playing any scary games to get
that intrinsic fear that rush the when
you can feel your heartbeat and those
are emotions that you don't just like
you said you don't feel mean your normal
day lies most of most of the time
and so it's fun I may that's why I think
you go to movies or you read books or is
to get these emotions that you're unable
to get otherwise art media makes you
feel things what about you when you're
playing your own game do you still get a
little bit nervous at times or is it
being so aware of how it's well that's
that's probably the biggest challenge
that you're so into it it's really hard
to pull back and figure out if it's
working on that so I mean at first you
trust your instinct and then you get
feedback on the team and after that it's
play test and reiterate and we do it I
mean you don't do a game you redo it
basically it's right the first time you
you do something it's never summer as
good as you hope you would be so it's
just you just have to stick to it and
work hard you just get a bunch of play
testers and put them in a room with a
mic and the louder the screams the
accessible you guys fail your game in
and I think this this gameplay clip
right here in the cornfields is so
indicative of what kind of different
types of atmosphere you guys are
creating here so there are people in
this cornfield that are searching for
you you got to stay out of their lights
you're hiding I mean it's a really
terrifying moment and it can see on the
left you can see left and right audio
which is really interesting because now
I'm starting to use like dynamic audio
cues to see if I can hide from people if
they're coming from the left or the
right it seems like there's going to be
more opportunity for that where you're
in even with the light even when you're
using the camera your view will be
obstructed and you have to find new ways
to filter through the environment and
get to the next area
I actually got killed in this cornfield
and it was it was really cool the audio
queues ended up helping me realize what
I could and could not do I ended up
hiding in a barrel and using the audio
cues to realize when I could leave so I
think that's really interesting there's
and I think it's really cool you guys
are inventing that kind of that kind of
these new these new gameplay mechanics
for the demo I know the barrel is really
interesting because a
you're some barrels with water in them
so if you can't your some of your senses
get distorted but like I said you can
you sound a lot to figure out if the
threat is closed or or or gone and
instantly in this part what we were
after is trying to make you feel like
the old village is after you our last
one was mostly about one guy chasing me
down a corridor like I suck this really
bad and so we're still going to have
that but we wanted also to mix it up and
have sections that are more open with
several enemies chasing at the same time
even though there seems to be a village
do of many people will there be an
overarching villain or one key person
that we will be fearing the most yeah I
think we're after the first off last one
we did all force mortem having many
enemies that are very typical
stereotypical and it's part of the brand
and so yes there going to be some
characters that are you gonna meet more
than once and actually the one you see
at the yeah I remember her yeah you're
gonna see her often she did she's
convinced that the God that has told her
to take care of you some of them almost
didn't seem well they just seemed a
little otherworldly in a sense I mean
that girl sure you could say she's just
a kid but she almost looked demon esque
you guys obviously are getting a lot of
inspirations from probably other horror
classics things that inspire you likes
grudge or poltergeist what types of
things have you guys been inspired by
for outlast there's The Shining there's
a Jacob's Ladder also a more recent
movie take shelter we liked a lot
I mean basically we take stuff we like
from very very varied places and we try
to merge them all into something that
feels fresh fresh and unique but
figuring out the school parts figuring
out how that ties in with everything
else is part of the experience
you're going to get some answers at some
point and maybe those answers will
change also based on your own perception
and philosophies that's really what
we're trying to achieve something that
when you're you finish it people have
different interpretations and argue
about it even among the team there are
different interpretations of what goes
on in the game so I'm really curious to
see how people react to it
now in terms of length of play the
original how would you say this compares
original and in terms of like clock
towers I should be a solid 25 30% longer
and in the first game so hopefully
closer to 10 hours then the first one
was between 5 and 7 I think this won't
be closer to 10 great and and that does
you know I remember actually replaying
the first one just kind of get a better
feel for it I think what's cool about
your game is even though a lot of these
types of games you might not want to
play again because you've seen it like
the jump scares and stuff but because
most of your fear is atmospheric you can
actually play it again and still get a
really nice vibe for what's going on
yeah I'm always amazed of reading
comments from players who've played it
several times and also we have a on the
first game we had a insane level of
difficulty which you can die if you die
you have to restart at the beginning I'm
always amazed to hear players who who've
done it because I haven't imagined dying
right before like the sixth hour and
just being like well I'll try again
tomorrow it's really cool if like when
you died it was like well that's that's
the only chance you had to play the game
yeah I became your dad life she comes in
and kills you in real life so is this
coming to consoles as well as PC
zakharik yep ps4 Xbox and PC at the same
time you know the first one we have to
ship them one at a time because you have
to put the pipeline in place but now
we've got the pipeline and so we're able
to ship them all at the same time
physical copies still in negotiations
yeah be cool to see other abilities to
get your game because your game is
something that's now quite close to
people they're really interested in
seeing what else they can have and they
want items to go along with it they want
collector's editions or something to
give them physical elements to remember
them to remember this game by yeah and
we are we're gonna put up a store I
don't know exactly when but it's part of
our plans I have some figurines and
stuff it's a yeah we it's just the fact
you know we're such a small team you
always have to bring back our focus to
production because otherwise it's easy
to get carried away and deal with other
stuff and just you know we I mean I
remember when we left our jobs we were
working in big studios and mostly doing
meetings and stuff like that and we
really want to go back to be hands-on
and work on the game so kind of an
ironic right now that the no wait now
that we've done it and we got our
company and we were able to work on the
game but at the same time there are just
so many things to take care of and deal
with so it's yeah it's a lot of work but
that's really satisfying at the same
time yeah I feel like it's a huge part
of your job to remind us that you're a
small team all the time so that people
don't get overwhelmed with their
expectations because we want it all
right and like that's just natural
especially with seeing the first game
and having so much quality with such a
small team in such a small timeframe I
mean now with all these resources I
think people have much higher
expectations does that is that something
that like motivates you guys are you
looking forward to reactions of the
public yeah I mean it's I guess it
depends on the day's news and some days
it's daunting but most of the time it's
just a motivation factor sorry a
motivation element and you know it's
it's it's always it's a it's flattering
when when you read people that they
think it's a big long triple-a game we
really have talented people on the team
and and we just work on it and we are
passionate about what we do I think
that's what makes a difference at the
end of the day yeah the good things
about indie games right you can really
tell the people who had their hands on
it yeah really care because there's so
many small touches that made me get lost
in the noise how's the big reaction I
think it's the the big keys to work on
something you would like to play
yourself and that makes a huge
difference if you if you're satisfied by
what you're making then it's going to
the defense in terms of equality
represent yeah cool it was pretty good
sneak peek but we got so far we've
gotten basically a fifteen minute demo a
lot of people can play and then some
gameplay clips out of that will there be
any other things that you guys will be
showing in the upcoming months for
people to look forward to before you
guys's release yeah I mean there's going
to be the comic book probably tons of
screenshots and definitely a new demo by
the end of summer probably either PAX
Prime or come Gamescom games come nice
new games come demo and this was like a
pretty good chunk like a 15 minute demo
can it really gives you the vibe of the
atmosphere the story so like we kind of
know we are a dude looking for his wife
there's that I think they get a whole
all begins like a helicopter crash
before that even there's like some
preliminary story that helps explain why
we're here and what we're doing in this
world so it'd be nice to even get more
snippets of that story when we can it's
always a challenge to true you know try
to find something that makes sense as a
demo but doesn't give away too much of
the old game but yeah I mean I think
it's part of the inner I guess as
artists you know you want always the
people to play it without you know as a
clean slate you know where they're not
knowing anything but that's that's not
reality you know you have to explain
what you're working on and have people
know a bit about the game before they
buy it but yes I honestly have no idea
what the next demo will be it's probably
going to be somewhere in the middle of a
middle of the game
but yeah I mean I'm really eager to see
people react to that we're going to be
showing some really edgy stuff in this
one we pushed it a bit in the
whistleblower but this time we're going
further and I wouldn't say I'm worried
but yeah I'm I'm curious to see how
people are gonna react to those is it
anything like your demo you're already
pushing the bar in terms of oh that's
nothing ah well my penis got cut off
I felt like I was pushed happened in the
demo show me this demo it's a really
cool there's a lot of gameplay that's
coming up now from everybody playing it
here at e3 and it's really intense to
see so I'm looking forward to seeing
more snippets of it you guys do not have
a release date yet though no I mean I'm
pretty sure the game calm confident the
game will get done this fall but we'll
see if it comes out just before the
holidays all right after ok so that was
out last two and that's on PC ps4 and
Xbox one sometime in the fall but that's
all we know so far so we'll have to wait
to see more all right well thank you so
much Philip for joining us for having me
yeah and thank you guys for watching
this is the GameSpot stage here at e3
and we actually have a lot more coming
up for you but not me sadly this is the
end of my hosting here but it's been
awesome hanging out with you guys and
please stick around we still have
several more live shows lots of cool
interviews some exclusive game claim
gameplay Clips almost got through it and
you guys aren't going to want to miss
anything so please stay tuned and I will
see you guys again later
you